every year in the forest somewhere in
Northern California there is a secret
ceremony far away from the watchful eyes
of the public and mainstream media the
attendees the most powerful and
influential people in the world
former U.S presidents powerful Business
Leaders Bankers CEOs and a few actors
and other artists the event is so secret
that ex-military men guard the area
equipped with night vision goggles
thermal cameras and motion detectors no
one is allowed to come close to this
area no one is allowed to see what's
about to happen sometimes even the
Secret Service is there to help out and
there is good reason for that
so he went and snuck in to this place
where like former presidents go there's
a photograph of it's uh Ronald Reagan
with Herbert Walker Bush and a couple
other people all standing around and
it's like these are the people that used
to hang out at this place and they would
put on robes and they would worship an
hour ago owl God and they would burn an
effigy and then no one's denying that
it's real this really did happen so
they're in with these bankers and former
presidents and they're dressed like
Druids and some guy brings over
something that it's an effigy that's
supposed to be a body a wrapped up
Effigy it's a bunch of sticks in Black
in a blanket but it's like shaped like a
body yeah and they drop it on the fire
and they're all worshiping an owl God
but what exactly are these powerful men
doing in this Forest is this the secret
society that runs the world is this
ceremony their chance to act out their
satanic fantasies or is it just a club
for the rich and Powerful to have a good
time far away from the public
my name is Jake Tran I make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
Instagram jaketran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
I would never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is Bohemian
Grove the most powerful secret society
in the world
foreign
[Music]
all these powerful people have one thing
in common they all have a great team
behind them the most accessible
companies out there are the ones with
the best team the same goes for my team
and this channel these videos would not
be as good without them that is why it's
so important to hire the right people
but the problem is finding the right
people is really tedious and expensive
you have to go through hundreds of
applications and resumes most of which
aren't a good match it's like trying to
find a needle in a haystack thankfully
that is where zip recruiter comes in the
number one rated hiring sites if you've
got a business and you're looking to
scale you've got to start using zip
recruiter ZipRecruiter is an online
Marketplace that helps connect top
employers with the very best applicants
thanks to their powerful AI matching
technology that matches you with the
right candidate for the right job that's
why on zip recruiter four out of every
five employers get a quality candidate
within the first day you can easily
review filter and rate recommended
candidates then you can personally
invite your top choices to apply and
then boom before you know it you've
found the perfect person that would take
your company to the next level plus ZIP
recruiter actually learns from your
ratings and sends you similar candidates
the future ZipRecruiter the smartest way
to hire in fact the hardest thing you
have to remember is my special URL
ziprecruiter.com Jake Tran that is where
you can go and try ZipRecruiter for free
once again that's zippercritter.com
[Music]
j-a-k-e-t-r-a-n thanks a zip recruiter
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
U.S politician with
a run for the presidency one day
it's a ruthless environment of
Washington DC your enemies are watching
your every move getting in your way
whenever they can they're trying to get
under your skin hoping that you fly off
the handle they're working to destroy
your reputation with nasty rumors they
leak to the Press they're trying to use
you as a puppet for their agenda but you
can't let any of that happen you want to
become U.S president after all so you
have to be on constant alert 24 hours a
day seven days a week fighting an uphill
battle every step of the way to make
things worse the mainstream media keeps
attacking you on a daily basis but you
can't show any sign of weakness so you
just shrug it off as if it's no big deal
but even though you seem calm and
collected on the outside all these
battles are starting to get under your
skin this presents a unique problem how
are you supposed to relieve all that
stress you can't just go to a nightclub
with a few buddies to get drunk and
dance the night away no no no you are a
powerful man in the public eye you have
a reputation to uphold the paparazzi he
would be all over that and if you let go
and act silly for just a second the
media would tear you apart one wrong
move one Scandal and your political
career is over but you have to blow off
some steam somehow otherwise you will
soon crack and have a complete mental
breakdown the solution a secret super
exclusive camping trip reserved for the
rich and Powerful Elite just like you a
place where you couldn't let go of all
your worries enjoy creepy rituals and
network with the most powerful people in
the world far away from the watchful
eyes of the public and the Press welcome
to Bohemian Grove
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the late 19th century San Francisco
was full of creative people with a
can-do spirit artists lived out their
creative streak in their paintings
novels and dramas
spring Of 1872 around 150 years ago a
group of writers actors and journalists
wanted to enjoy their art in a more
exclusive and private setting so they
founded the Bohemian Club a kind of
secret society where artists could
express themselves freely in all their
unique ways far away from all the
ignorant people out there in the real
world there was just one problem most
artists were quite poor it's one thing
to express yourself artistically and
live the Bohemian lifestyle but at some
point you gotta pay rent so the leaders
of the Bohemian Club had an idea why not
invite a few rich businessmen who
appreciate the Arts they could enjoy the
exclusive atmosphere of the club and
brag about being friends with real
artists of San Francisco and in return
they could show their gratitude with
some financial support it was a
brilliant move all of a sudden these
artists could live out their wildest
ideas while being supported by their
sugar daddies their time as Starving
Artists was finally over now they just
had to find a secret spot to enjoy their
art together and soon they found the
perfect place a redwood forest near
Monte Rio California or what they called
The Bohemian Grove they built camps for
their members with strange names like
Lost Angels Owl's Nest and caveman and
every Camp would be home to a few
members who could get drunk together
build close friendships and live out
their artistic Spirit but even though it
seemed like heaven on Earth the fate of
the club would soon take a dramatic turn
foreign
[Applause]
you may think that these artists were
living the dream that they could run
wild with their ideas while collecting
money from their rich friends but with
so much money and Status floating around
the club's Dynamic quickly changed
only eight years after the club's
founding a group of painters and writers
complained that the club had become too
commercialized too mainstream and that
the true Bohemian Spirit was dead all
this money and social aspirations meant
death to genius and a general dead level
mediocrity artists were slowly being
replaced by the powerful and Wealthy
Elite of the country Bankers industry
leaders CEOs leading scientists they all
wanted to join the exclusive party and
their money and influence made
creativity take a back seat
then another tribe of powerful men
joined the club U.S presidents Dwight
Eisenhower Ronald Reagan Richard Nixon
George Bush Senior they all joined the
Bohemian club before they became
president of the United States George
Bush Senior joined the club in 1973 and
moved into the camp called Hillbillies
his roommates top Executives from Bank
of America and General Motors two years
later Ronald Reagan was inducted into
the Bohemian Club and moved into the
Owl's Nest Camp while George Bush was
chatting with the president of the Bank
of America Reagan was hanging out with
the CEO of United Airlines
you may think that with so many powerful
people rubbing shoulders they make
plenty of shady business deals or come
up with secret plans to rule the world
but the club has a strict rule weaving
spiders come not here meaning no
networking no business deals no secret
plans the Bohemian Grove is a place to
let go of your worries enjoy the Arts
and get wasted
but as you already know rules are made
to be broken it's safe to say that
everyone goes to Bohemian Grove with
their own agenda and how could you blame
them over a nice dinner in the
wilderness next to CEOs and presidents
secret deals happen on their own
it's rumored that the early planning
stage of the infamous Manhattan Project
happened during the Bohemian Grove in
1942 only three years later atomic bombs
were dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
leveling both cities and putting an end
to World War II
[Music]
one of the highlights of the Bohemian
Grove are the so-called Lakeside talks
the off the Record speeches by
politicians and business leaders it's a
chance for these powerful men to talk
about their agenda to bend the world in
their Vision far away from quarters
politicians especially love giving a
Lakeside it's the perfect chance to get
some exposure without violating the
club's rule number one weaving spiders
come not here it's just a casual chat by
A club member after all but in reality
it may be the first day of their
presidential campaign they can share
some of their ideas with the most
powerful people in the country see how
they react and find out who might back
them should they decide to run for the
presidency and the one man who knows the
importance of these Lakeside talks
better than anyone else is Richard Nixon
in 1950 Nixon listened to Eisenhower's
Lakeside speech which must have Charmed
the right people Nixon later said quote
it struck me forcibly that Eisenhower's
personality and a personal Mystique had
deeply impressed to the skeptical and
critical caveman audience end quote
three years later Eisenhower became the
next U.S president 17 years later it was
time for Nixon's own Lakeside speech at
that point he was considered damaged
goods because of his failed candidacy a
few years earlier so this time he had to
prove himself all over again and it was
a huge success two years after his
Lakeside speech Nixon moved into the
Oval Office he later wrote quote if I
were to choose the speech that gave me
the most pleasure and satisfaction in my
political career it would be my Lakeside
speech at the Bohemian Grove in July
1967 because this speech traditionally
was off the record it received no
publicity at the time but in many
important ways it marked the first
Milestone on my road to the presidency
end quote
three years later Nixon wanted to give
another speech now as president of the
United States there was just one small
problem the U.S president can't just
disappear to get hammered in a forest
and give a private speech to the most
powerful men in the country when the
Press heard about it they said they
would join the party to cover the event
and they had a few questions in mind
what were all these powerful men doing
in a secluded forest in the middle of
nowhere what were they talking about is
anything going on here that the public
should know about it wasn't exactly what
the Bohemian Club wanted their secret
rituals and speeches had to be protected
at all costs so the club leaders told
Nixon to sit this one out in 1995 former
President George Bush Senior used his
Lakeside speech to introduce a special
guest his son George W bush and he had a
clear message for his audience his son
would make a great president one day
and we all know how that one turned out
on my orders Coalition forces have begun
striking selected targets of military
importance to undermine Saddam Hussein's
ability to wage war Easley these
Lakeside speeches are still one of the
best kept secrets in America no one
knows what they're talking about each
year and it's quite difficult to sneak
around all those ex-military soldiers
guarding the place so if you want to see
these Lakeside talks live so you know
exactly what the powerful Elite is
planning next maybe it's time for you to
become a member of this secret society
and here is how step number one have an
impressive career in politics or
business preferably both step number two
get at least two Bohemian club members
to invite you to the club and have them
vouch for your remarkable character step
number three impress the membership
committee show them that you have what
it takes to be a good Bohemian if you
have a talent for acting and drama
that's a big plus step number four scrub
any history of you watching this channel
step number five pray that the majority
of the membership committee votes for
you when it's time to pick new members
step number six enjoy your time being on
the waiting list for the next five to
ten years but don't just sit around use
the time to become even richer and more
powerful
step number seven you're finally
accepted great welcome to the Bohemian
club now it's time to pay the Initiation
fee of twenty five thousand dollars but
you're a multi-millionaire by now so
that's chump change
step number eight get ready for the
creepy ritual to kick off the yearly
summer camp
now that you've made it into this secret
society it's time for your first
Bohemian Grove and just like every year
it begins with a strange ritual called
The Cremation of care a dark tradition
meant to let you go of all your worries
and responsibilities as you're standing
there in the middle of the forest
surrounded by millionaires billionaires
and future presidents all with the same
tense faces you feel that something
strange is about to happen suddenly you
see a few men in red robes and red hoods
marching forward some of them are
playing sad music others are carrying
long torches but they're carrying
something else and
coffin
you take a step closer and risk a look
inside is that a human body is this some
kind of Satanic ritual but then you look
more closely and see that it's just a
human effigy a model of a person or
maybe it is a real person who knows
they call it the body of care and it
represents all the worries and woes that
the powerful Elite is carrying on their
shoulders every single day but now it's
time to burn all those worries away for
good or at least for a few days the men
slowly keep marching forward to the
altar where Mr care is about to get
sacrificed under the watchful eye of a
giant owl Yes you heard that right the
most powerful men in the country Wrapped
in Red robes are about to burn a human
effigy in front of a giant owl after the
choir finishes their song the high
priest announces that the pyre is
waiting for the body of care a pyre is a
heap of stuff that is to be lit on fire
the men carry the coffin to the pyre in
front of the owl and it seems like Mr
care is about to meet his maker but then
Mr care makes it clear that he's not
gonna go down without a fight after some
intense back and forth the priest has
heard enough he grabs a torch and lights
the body of Care on fire as the Flames
leap higher and higher all the worries
of the powerful Elite Melt Away
[Music]
is the Bohemian Grove just a summer camp
for powerful men who want to let go of
their worries for a moment or do they
actually use it to craft secret plans to
rule over Society far away from the
public eye most likely both after all
with so many powerful men coming
together in a secluded Forest secured by
ex-military men it's hard not to discuss
secret plans like the cia's MK Ultra
program for example during the Cold War
the CIA believed the Soviets had found a
way to turn everyday people into
emotionless puppets that would do
anything they told them to include
killing others without any sense of
remorse but instead of being horrified
by the idea the CIA was intrigued so
they started their own little side
project called MK Ultra the scientists
behind MK Ultra would test all sorts of
drugs and torture techniques on as many
people as they could one of their
objectives was to turn their victims
into a so-called Manchurian Candidate a
programmed killer who would kill on
command and forget about it a moment
later it's one of the darkest chapters
in CIA history
talking about all the details of MK
Ultra the psychological torture the LSD
experiments and all the brainwashing was
beyond the scope of this video
besides the Vivid details of torture
would trigger all kinds of red flags
with the YouTube algorithm luckily we've
released a deep dive into every dark
evil secret MK Ultra holds as a private
documentary available only to members of
this Channel and members have been
loving the documentary all you have to
do to get to watch this private
documentary right now and all the other
documentary length videos that are too
controversial too dark too risky to post
publicly is click the join button below
once you sign up you'll get exclusive
access to MK Ultra the CIA coup in Iran
CIA black cites the bin Laden papers
every jepstein and many more to come
these are the things they should be
teaching you in University about how the
world works but they don't and unlike
University you get all of this for just
five dollars a month and there's a
refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund so scroll down and hit that join
button now
I have been wanting to do this video for
a really long time so let me know what
you thought about it in the comments
below and if you're new here my name is
Jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on YouTube for documentaries on
money power war and crime so if you
enjoyed this one click that subscribe
button below because we make multiple
documentaries just like this one every
single week for free and if you want
shorter versions of these videos you can
follow me on Facebook but that's going
to wrap it up stay dangerous out there
and I will see you guys in the next one
foreign
[Music]